I stayed away for 24 hours in the
Slytherin common room and found the most
absent-minded student in the history of
Hogwarts seriously this kid would have
made Neville Longbottom look like he had
it all together he kept pulling out this
ball and bouncing it wait I wonder if
this is a remembral what even is the
point of a remembral ever heard of a
pensive by the way we named the kid
Billy Billy the Kid he refused to take
off that first year cap stayed up with
us all night by the way too the only
other Slytherin in the common room to do
so we started to get suspicious why is
he staying up all night to bounce his
remember all and stare at a notice board
does this guy think he's the heir of
Slytherin kid didn't even take a moment
for a snack at least Joshua was studying
that somehow makes sense but Billy
there's no sense to his madness Okay now
I do have to come clean I actually
wasn't completely truthful in the
beginning because not only did we stay
up 24 hours we actually ended up
following Billy for 36 hours just when
we are about to call it quits Billy went
to a completely new spot we hadn't seen
him go to before and you know what he
did I kid you not he started to nod off
falling asleep